Welcome to the David Pakman show.
Uh, Benjamin Dixon filling in for David while
he is in Los Angeles, uh, preparing to a appear
on the Joe Rogan podcast.
I think, um, out of all of the intellectual
dark web Joe Rogan is the only show I'd go
on and not instantly be adversarial.
So I'm sure there's going to be a wonderful
conversation between David and Joe.
Uh, so be sure to check that out later on
today.
Speaking of today, today is my birthday.
So if you want to do something for me, go
to the Benjamin Dixon, show a youtube channel
and subscribe.
Let's get to the news.
Donald Trump and his administration have demonstrated
that they are willing to buck, are to all
out, ignore the checks and balances that have
been set forth by the constitution.
Um, CNN reporter yesterday that the administration
instructed hope Hicks, um, former assistant
to the president to not comply with requests
from Congress to turn over documents, uh,
to the house judiciary.
Um, also this, I mean, this is just the latest
in a series of events, uh, in a, in a series
of outright refusal to comply with the checks
and balances that would come from Congress
or the judiciary.
Uh, last week the, uh, Justice Department
said that they would not turn over documents
to a federal judge who requested the documents.
In the sentencing of Michael Flynn, we have
attorney general bar who refused to testify
before the Senate ignoring their subpoena.
Um, and so this is really just, just a, a,
a very interesting time.
It's many people are considering it to be
a constitutional crisis.
I don't agree.
I don't think it's constitutional crisis because
there's actually remedies, uh, to this problem.
Congress has the ability to hold any of these
people with, uh, in contempt of Congress.
The federal judiciary has any of the federal
judges rather have the ability to hold people
who do not comply with a request from the
court.
Our court orders, they have the ability to
hold them in contempt of court, but if they
don't do those things, that's where the problem
comes in.
That's where it becomes optional.
Subpoena really doesn't mean anything if there's
no enforcement behind it.
And this is where, this is where I believe
that our system is falling short, not because
we don't have a solution to the problems that
the Trump administration is presenting us.
It's rather that we have, we have people who
are not really ready to institute are to carry
out those solutions.
Uh, so congress does have the ability to remedy
these things, but before we get into the,
the remedy, the really is something that's
significant to see.
Um, forgive the alliteration there, but it's
very, it's very, it's something to see in
our lifetime to see the president of the United
States who not only personally challenges
the judiciary, uh, on Twitter.
Anytime there's a court ruling that he doesn't
like, he goes on on a, on a tirade and he
undermines the legitimacy of the judiciary
in front of the entire nation and the entire
world for that matter.
Um, he does the same thing with Congress.
He undermines the validity of Congress over
and over and over again.
And I was reading an article in the American
prospect, uh, an opinion piece by Robert Reich,
former secretary of labor, Labor Secretary
for Bill Clinton.
And he really just outlined it.
The, the, the job of the president is to protect
the institutions, um, uh, of the, uh, American
institutions.
And this is quite the opposite of what Donald
Trump is doing.
Donald Trump goes on his tirades.
He, he goes on his temper tantrums and he
undermines the very institutions, uh, any
undermines the constitution that he took an
oath to uphold.
Not that any of that matters to Donald Trump,
nor does any of that matter to Donald Trump's
supporters because they have already demonstrated
that they are willing to go with Donald Trump,
no matter how far, uh, it takes, uh, it takes
them.
There was one video that I think we've covered
on this show, um, where, uh, a supporter of
Donald Trump said that she, she never thought
that she would want a dictator, but if she
ever gets a dictator, she wants it to be Donald
Trump.
Now, uh, that's just the, that's just one
example.
But if you really thinking about it, what
can Donald Trump actually do to lose trust
amongst his most ardent supporters?
I mean, he literally is betraying the constitution
every day.
And for people who swear, they are so concerned
about American patriotism, they're so concerned
about upholding the constitution, they feel
like they're originalists are they?
They're going to interpret the constitution
in an originalist fashion.
You would think that this will set off an
alarm for them.
But Republicans have demonstrated that they
are absolutely willing to just be quiet about
the president of the United States, ignoring
the checks and balances and not just the president.
Mind you, it's the president and his administration
intentionally ignoring the checks and balances
that are put forth, are set forth in the constitution
as well as every day or any time the president
is upset with Congress or with a judge, he
actively undermines that institution, those
institutions.
And so that's the problem.
And we're, we're, we're, we're thinking that
there's conversations if think pieces of whether
or not this is a constitutional crisis, but
it's not really a constitutional crisis until
you attempt to use the remedies in the constitution.
And then those remedies have no, are not actually
recognize or they're not actual remedies.
For instance, if you hold, um, if you hold
William Barr in contempt of Congress, right?
Uh, and he refuses are here or there is a,
there is a, an attempt to refuse to be arrested
and held in contempt, then you have a problem.
Right?
Um, or if the president of the United States
ignores, you know, the president of the United
States ignoring the norms and the institutions
is one things.
And what, and what I mean by norms and institutions,
I mean, they're, they're traditions that are
just as important or more easily recognized,
like the decorum, the, a, the ability to respect
the decision of Congress even though you don't
like the decision of Congress.
Uh, the peaceful transition of power.
Those things are like institutional norms.
Those are things that America does just out
of habit.
And those are the things that Donald Trump
is really undermining, uh, in addition to
the actual constitution.
But, but the decorum part is not a constitutional
crisis.
It becomes a constitutional crisis.
When Congress attempts to use the tools at
their disposal to put Donald Trump in check,
and he ignores them, like, can't really ignore
it.
And the peach meant process, right?
He can't really ignore an impeachment inquiry.
And those are some of the tools that they
have at their disposal.
But if Congress never uses them, uh, then
the president of the United States is able
to carry on a without any repercussions for
ignoring, uh, for ignoring the checks and
balances that are set forth in the constitution.